Hello
Hello?
Um..? Hello?
What's going on? Where am I?
I think you're dead
What do you mean?
Like you died as in no longer alive
I was literally just driving home from work everything was fine
Yeah! and then you died, car accident I think
But I.. I don't remember anything
Yeah I think that's typically how death works
is this like a
a prank or something or a dream maybe?
That'd be kind of a weird prank
to knock you unconscious and then wake you up
in some weird, empty, white room with no doors or windows
don't you think?
I guess it's sort of like a dream though, but... no
You're definitely just dead
Wait so who are you? Are, are you God?
(suppressed laughter) I wish but... no.
I'm you. Kind of. I'm at least who you thought you were.
You know, the voice you've had in your head since you were a little kid
when you started to understand language and all that
That's me. Or... you
Or technically just your brain,
or really just the part of your brain you attached "you" to
so you could have a sense of self.
Either way, it's all just semantics.
Probably just don't recognize me on account of
you know, being dead
and all the chemicals in your brain are being flushed out
and I'm sure that's making things kind of confusing
but, I'm still here
at least for a tiny bit longer
and then what?
Good question.
Okay, and?
I have no idea. I'm you, remember? What you know I know and, vice versa.
All I know is I'm here for right now
and based on what I've heard about dying
you're about to see your whole life pass as it gets drained out of you.
You're going to see it for what it really was, objectively.
Free from the pressures of actually being there.  Free from your ego.
Free from me. It's going to be intense.
Okay, wh- when is this going to happen?
Now.
[Same voice overlapping itself unintelligibly]
-They loved you and trusted you.
-Even though you loved Sarah.
-You drank too much.
[Continued unintelligible sentences]
[Continued]
-You took too long so she moved on.
-You worked really hard but gave up a third of your life for a company that
-made you feel scared all the time
[Continued]
-You never really [untintelliglbe] stood up for yourself
-You rushed into a marriage not because you found the right person
-You always wanted to stop
[Continued]
-time
-China
-have more time
-sail and write a book
So you never did.
(sigh)
Okay. It's over now.
Makes so much sense. I g- I get it. I know exactly where I went wrong
and what to do differently now.
I'm going to take time to reconnect with friends and not let new friendships fizzle out
just 'cause of laziness. I'm going to be nicer and more understanding
instead of being so impatient and reserved.
I'm going to be more attentive and caring to my wife and not always need to be right when we argue but
actually care about resolving the issue.
I'm going to forgive my parents and ask them to forgive me.
I'm going to forgive myself.
I'm going to spend time towards myself.
I'm going to be healthier, eat better,
exercise, feel good, and not procrastinate on things I want to see and experience.
I'm going to take chances on the things that matter to me.
I'm gonna actually be myself and like myself instead of always hiding it
and feeling bad about it.
I'm gonna laugh more and worry less.
I'm not gonna let little things ruin entire days anymore.
I'm gonna enjoy life for what it is and not be so serious and worried and sad and anxious all the time
for no good reason. I'm going to-
Whoa whoa whoa whoa. No.
You won't. You won't do any of that. You're dead.
Remember? That was it.
Now it's about to be gone forever.
I'm about to be gone forever.
Wai- wai- wait. Hold on. I- Is
Thank you for watching.
If you found enjoyment and value in this video, please give it a thumbs up.
Share your thoughts in the comments below.
And if you are not already, be sure to subscribe to our channel.
We are constantly coming out with new videos
to help you experience life
with clarity and wonder.